Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
Here’s part two of my Doctor Who 50th Anniversary
easter eggs.
I thought it would be fun to try and find
all the hidden references in the 50th anniversary
but there were so many I had to break it into
two parts.
This part will just cover everything in the
second half of the broadcast.
I think in total I did about 33 or 34 easter
eggs in the first video.
So let’s see if we can top that without
making an hour long video.
Also, I’m getting lots of Christmas Special
questions about Peter Capaldi being the 14th
Doctor or even the valeyard.
I’m going to do a video about that next
week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Let the easter egg hunt begin.
If you’re following along these are in chronological
order of appearance starting right after the
first appearance of captain jack’s vortex
manipulator.
Starting things off, The Vortex Manipulator
code.
Matt Smith carves into the wall is actually
the date and time the very first episode of
doctor who aired.
The Painting.
Because Matt Smith’s doctor called from
the past for the security guard to move the
painting before present day clara entered
the black archive.
It’s already there when she first arrives.
The Oldest Operating System In the universe.
The sonic screwdrivers are used to open the
door in the tower of London.
This works because each doctor regenerates
and gets a new sonic, but the software inside
each sonic is the same.
Meaning you could start running a program
and it would continue to run through each
regeneration.
That would be like buying a new computer every
couple of years but still running it on MS-DOS.
Making SonicOS the oldest operating system
in the universe.
Next to the operating system of the moment.
How Old is the Doctor.
Matt Smith answers that he’s about 1200
years old.
Unless I’m lying.
Rule number one is the doctor lies, but he
also forgets things.
Steven Moffat also said in a recent interview
that the doctor doesn’t know which number
regeneration he is.
So while audiences know him as 11, he could
actually be a higher number.
You’ve met them before.
Matt Smith reminds clara that she’s met
every version of the doctor thanks to jumping
into his time stream during the events of
The name of the doctor.
She’d only be able to remember that she
met them if the doctor was able to re-integrate
all of the versions of clara when he also
went into his own time stream to rescue her.
She dodges the question, so we don’t get
confirmation.
Meaning she could just be a different version
of the original clara.
Cuppa Soup.
The Doctor refers to the stasis cube as a
cuppa soup.
Why?
Because it’s bachelor food.
And as advanced as the doctor is, he’s very
lonely and eats lonely depressing bachelor
food.
Like Cuppa soups.
Does this happen a lot.
The Doctor gets kissed a lot, but which doctor
gets the most face time?
Just speaking about the new doctors, number
9 got kissed twice, number 10 got kissed 9
times and number 11 has gotten kissed 8 times
so far.
Making David Tennant the snogging champion
pending any kissy moments in the christmas
special.
I’ll be right back.
Number 10 didn’t see Elizabeth again until
the events of The Elizabeth Code.
Which might be why she wants to chop his head
off.
Matt Smith’s doctor also says the exact
same thing to a young Amelia Pond before returning
12 years late.
And it also kind of looks like she wants to
chop his head off for a little while.
Back to the future.
This is a nice reference to the Back to the
future franchise.
I don’t think Michael J Fox was on set that
day.
The round things.
These are a reference to the classic doctor’s
tardises.
Starting with william hartnell up to the 8th
doctor’s tardis.
Each interior had a similar version of the
‘round things’ on the walls.
You’ve redecorated.
Tennant’s doctor says this, and it’s the
same thing the second doctor said during the
three doctor’s 10th anniversary special.
Matt Smith also says it to Craig in Closing
Time during series 6.
The humans don’t realize what half this
stuff does.
In case you missed them.
These are river song’s red shoes from The
Time of The Angels.
Magna Clamps.
These are torchwood’s magna clamps first
seen in Army of Ghosts and then later in Doomsday.
The cancel an objects mass, making large objects
easy to lift.
The spacetime telegraph.
This was like the classic version of the doctor’s
phone number that the fourth doctor gave to
brigadier general.
He first used it to summon the doctor during
revenge of the cybermen and later terror of
the zygons.
The doctor’s phone number.
This is the same phone number the doctor has
had since Stolen earth in series 4.
The big red button.
This flower like button is an homage to Rose
Tyler.
Because although billie piper is in the special
she’s not playing Rose or Bad Wolf.
The sound of the tardis.
The Moment tells John hurt that the sound
means hope to all who hear it.
But River Song let us know that the tardis
isn’t actually supposed to make that sound.
The Doctor has just been doing it wrong ever
since he stole it.
Or it stole him.
For my next trick.
During the final montage when all 13 doctor’s
are on screen in order to make the scene work.
The production team used stock footage from
the previous doctors, including Christopher
Eccleston, who declined to participate in
the episode.
Had he said yes his part would probably have
been expanded from this quick moment.
All 13.
Peter Capaldi is credited by the high council
as a doctor in a very brief cameo, but he’s
not listed as a doctor in the the credits.
We know Matt Smith will regenerate in the
christmas special, but we don’t know how
Steven Moffat is going to deal with the 13
regenerations limit.
I hope the ears are a bit less conspicuous
this time.
This is a joke about christopher eccleston,
who’s ears stick out from his head a lot.
The special effects team even morphs john
hurt’s face just a little to look like eccleston’s
during the regeneration.
I don’t want to go.
This is a reference to David Tennant’s final
words before regenerating into the 11th doctor.
Matt Smith responds with “He always says
that..”
The Great curator.
Tom Baker makes his illustrious appearance.
In the background on the wall are circles
resembling his tardis and he even tells the
11th doctor the secret of the painting and
that the doctor might find himself revisiting
old favorite faces in the future.
This implies that the doctor eventually finds
a way past his regeneration limit and since
we already know regenerations can be controlled
he could totally be a future version of the
doctor that regenerated into a similar version
of his fourth self.
It also opens the door to the classic doctors
appearing on the show in the future.
So be sure to write any other extra references
you caught in the comments.
Remember this video is just the second half
of the special.
All the stuff from the first half is in my
part 1 video.
Since this took so long to make I’m pushing
my Sherlock Series 3 video to Sunday before
Walking Dead.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Dont’ forget I’m also doing a regeneration
video next week too.
I’ll post it on Thursday.
Right now click here for part 1 of my 50th
easter eggs and click here to learn all about
the christmas special.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!